My husband got home from a four day work trip last night,
so I decided to make us a big family dinner tonight.
Summer always makes me crave Greek food,
so that's exactly what I got started on tonight.
Started by making some pita dough and as soon as it came together,
I turned it out and started kneading it.
Halfway through I got too tired to continue,
so lucky took over since he's really good at kneading dough.
Once it was smooth, I put it in my bowl,
covered it, and let it rise for about two to three hours
while I got started on my lamb.
Making a slow cooked lamb today,
so I stuffed my lamb with some garlic,
some dried and fresh herbs,
some lemon, some onion.
I put that in the oven at a very low temperature
for about six to seven hours
while I got started on my tzatziki.
I combined some homemade Greek yogurt,
shaved cucumber, dill,
red wine vinegar, lemon,
olive oil,
and then popped that in the fridge until it was time for dinner.
And in the meantime, got started on my Greek salad.
It's tomato season right now,
so I had to take advantage of that.
Chopped up all my vegetables,
added some feta cheese, have the dressing.
Very simple. About an hour and a half before dinner was getting served,
I started on my Greek potatoes.
I season those
and then pop them in the oven for about an Hour and a half.
Once my dough had doubled in size,
I sectioned it into eight little balls,
let those rise for about 10 minutes on the counter
before rolling them out.
I then transferred my dough over to a hot skillet,
kept flipping it every 10 to 15 seconds until puffed up,
and I repeated that with all of my pita.
And then it was time to serve dinner.
We had the Greek salads, Ezekiel,
Greek potatoes, some pita,
and the slow roasted lamb. It was so divine.